dans sa maison yvelinoise dans la petite
ville dans de l'ue michael mokongo 35
ans se remémore les plus grands moments
de sa carrière de sportif professionnel
une aventure qu'il a commencé à l'âge de
7 ans dans son pays natal en république
centrafricaine avec un père lui aussi
basketteur c'est vrai que mon papa elle
est partie à barcelone les jeux de
barcelone pas ce qui les faisait partie
de l'équipe qui a accompagné l'équipe
centrafricaine est absent au retour une
ramenée à un petit panier de basket en
république centrafricaine et c'est là
que j'ai je suis tombé amoureux du
basket et jusque là j'ai pas quitter ce
sport-là miquel mont congo arrive en
france à l'âge de 10 ans et intègre
rapidement le centre de formation de
chalon le sportif débutant
professionnelle à l'âge de 17 ans et
demi en première division très vite
remarqué le découvre plusieurs pays
comme la turquie chypre ou encore
l'espagne mais c'est avec monaco que le
basketteur connaissait plus belles
émotions de 2013 à 2015 trois belles
années où on a monté le club de national
jusqu'en 1ère division et je garde que
les très bons souvenirs de la ville de
la structure les dirigeants de mes
coéquipiers avec qui on a pu jouer
c'était vraiment une belle expérience
pendant trois ans oui j'ai tourné à peu
près à 15 points de moyenne 15 points et
5 passes de moyenne
donc j'étais assez régulier pendant
pendant toutes ces années là celui que
l'on surnomme affectueusement mike joue
également en équipe nationale après
avoir porté les couleurs de l'équipe de
france ont moins de 18 et moins de 20
ans le basketteur décide d'intégrer
l'équipe de république centrafricaine
le meneur de jeu est devenu le leader de
cette nation pendant une décennie
c'est une fierté pour moi de pouvoir
représenter mon pays d'origine
et franchement j'ai fait quatre coupes
d'afrique
ça c'est vraiment très très bien passé
et je regrette pas du tout j'espère
pouvoir faire une dernière coupe
d'afrique encore avec l'équipe
centrafricaine cet été à kigali pour
terminer sa carrière mike a choisi les
yvelines le sportif d'un mètre
quatre-vingt joue dans le club de
trappes en nationale 3 son objectif
guidé l'équipe trappistes en troisième
division
j'aime beaucoup la mentalité j'aime bien
la diversité qui a attrapé et
je pense que la région mérite d'avoir un
club à ce niveau là donc
donc voilà je prends à coeur ce projet
là pour pouvoir vraiment les aider
c'est vrai que la loco vide nous
facilite pas les choses
on espère que l'année prochaine on
pourra bien reprendre la saison mike
congo voudrait encore jeu pendant deux à
trois saisons pour aider trappe dans ses
objectifs et surtout transmettre ses
connaissances aux jeunes basketteurs en
parallèle ce fan de kobe bryant va
continuer à mener une carrière de
commentateur sportif pour des chaînes
nationales